President Trump says he will respond
forcefully to what he calls the
atrocious use of chemical weapons by
Syria's government the regime is
suspected of attacking the rebel-held
town of Duma outside Damascus with corn
with a chlorine agent more than 40
people reportedly died the president
said a US response is imminent and it
may extend to Syria's allies Iran and
Russia we can't let that happen in our
world we can't let that happen
especially when we're able to because of
the power of the United States because
of the power of our country we're able
to stop it
sat down is traveling in the region
right now he's along the Syria Lebanon
border with Russia's latest response to
the attack good morning we are just a
few miles from the border with Syria
president Trump has called that
suspected chlorine attack barbaric
specifically referencing images of sick
suffocating and dying children and the
president has indicated that all options
including military ones are on the table
the Russian Defense Ministry released
this video which they say shows their
own military's investigation into the
attack and claimed they found no traces
of poisonous substances Moscow has
dismissed allegations of a chemical
attack as fake news following last
year's use of the internationally banned
sarin nerve agent in the Syrian town of
hansha Kuhn the Trump administration
struck Syria with Tomahawk cruise
missiles while Syria has been repeatedly
accused of using chlorine as a weapon it
has not yet prompted a military response
from the Trump administration a strike
from the US would be a new precedent and
could risk escalating tensions with
Syria's allies Iran and Russia whose UN
Ambassador has warned of grave
repercussions if the u.s. launched a
military strike for CBS this morning
I'm Seth Doane in Stora Lebanon